.
TREY: GOOD EVENING THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US, I AM -- TREY GOWDY.
WELCOME TO "SUNDAY NIGHT IN
AMERICA."
FAIRNESS IS OFTEN REQUIRES A
REFEREE, WE DON'T HAVE TO LIKE
THE REFEREE, BUT WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO RESPECT THE REFEREE.
THE MOST RECENT EXAMPLE OF
DUPLICITY AND UNFAIRNESS IS
MATTER IN WHICH CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATIONS ARE HANDLED BY
POLITICAL PARTIES AND MEDIA, DC
MEDIA NEVER MET A REPUBLICAN
INVESTIGATION THAT SHOULD START
OR DEMOCRAT INVESTIGATION THAT
SHOULD END WITH "FAST AND
FURIOUS," YOU WOULD THINK TWO
GROUPS ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT GUN
CONTROL WOULD BE INTERESTING IN
U.S. AIDING AND ABETTING THE
FLOW OF GUNS TO MEXICAN DRUG
CARTEL, MOST DEMOCRATS IN THE
MEDIA DID NOT CARE, BENGHAZI?
MORE DEMOCRATS VOTED TO
INVESTIGATE WHAT HAPPENED IN
BENGHAZI, LIBYA THAN REPUBLICANS
VOTED TO INVESTIGATE THE JANUARY
6 ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL.
DID YOU KNOW THAT?
DID YOU KNOW MORE DEMOCRATS
VOTED TO FORM A SELECT COMMITTEE
TO INVESTIGATE THE DEATHS OF 4
AMERICANS.
IN LIBYA THAN REPUBLICANS VOTED
FOR THE JANUARY 6 SELECT
COMMITTEE.
OF COURSE YOU DIDN'T.
THE MEDIA WANTS YOU BELIEVE ONE
INQUIRY WAS A WITCH-HUNT AND THE
OTHER IS BIPARTISAN AND SERIOUS.
I'M NOT TRYING TO CHANGE YOUR
MIND ON ANY OF THOSE
INVESTIGATIONSES, YOU ARE FREE
TO THINK THEY WERE WORTH
PURSUING OR NOT PURSUING, I DID
HAPPEN TONG WHAT HAPPEN --
HAPPEN TO THINK WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6 IS WORTHY OF
INVESTIGATION, PROSECUTION AND
INCARCERATION FOR THOSE
CONVICTED.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT MERITS OF THE
INVESTIGATION, I THINK WE COULD
ALL AGREE SAME STANDARD, SAME
RULES, SAME PROCESS SHOULD APPLY
TO ALL CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATIONS, REGARDLESS OF
WHO?
POWER, THE RULES SHOULD NOT
CHANGE DEPENDING ON WHICH TEAM
IS UP TO BAT AND THE STRIKE ZONE
SHOULD NOT CHANGE.
KEVIN McCARTHY PICKED 5
REPUBLICANS TO POPULATE JANUARY
6 COMMITTEE, HIGHEST RANGING
REPUBLICAN IN CONGRESS.
AND THEIR, HE PICKS THE REPORT
MEMBERS.
BUT NANCY PELOSI REJECTED TWO OF
HIS PICKS.
SHE REFUSED TO ALLOW THEM TO
PARTICIPATE.
SHE DEEMED THEM UNQUALIFIED.
WE'RE NOT SURE WHY SHE REJECTED
LEADER McCARTHY'S PICKS.
THE DC MEDIA IS TOO AFRAID OF
HER TO ASK, TO AFRAID OF LOSING
AN INTERVIEW OR NOT BE ON
RECEIVING END OF A LEAK.
THE DC MEDIA TELLS US THEY SPEAK
TRUTH TO POWER THAT DEMOCRACY
DIES IN DARKNESS, AND THEY
PUBLISH ALL THE NEWS THAT IS FIT
TO PRINT.
BUT THEY CAN'T QUESTION PELOSI
ON HER OPEN DUPLICITY WHEN IT
COMES TO CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATION, SHE PIT ADAM
SCHIFF ON THE BENGHAZI
COMMITTEE, EVEN THOUGH HIS MIND
WAS FULLY MADE UP, HE DID
EVERYTHING HE COULD TO PROTECT
THE DEMOCRAT NOMINEE FOR
PRESIDENT.
THAT WAS HIS JOB.
NOT TO INTERVIEW SURVIVORS, NOT
TO ACCESS INFORMATION, NOT TO
ASCERTAIN WHY THE MILITARY DID
NOT RESPOND IN A TIMELY MANNER,
BUT PROTECT HILLARY CLINTON.
PELOSI PICKED HIM DESPITE HIS
BIAS.
SHE ALSO PICKED SCHIFF TO
INVESTIGATE DONALD TRUMP OVER
RUSSIA COLLUSION ALLEGATIONS,
EVEN THOUGH SCHIFF MISSTATED
EVIDENCE, PREJUDGED OUTCOME AND
CLAIMED TO HAVE EVIDENCE HE
NEVER PRODUCED.
SHE PICKED SCHIFF TO LEAD THE
PROSECUTION AND A FAILED
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL, EVEN THOUGH
HE MISSTATED FACTS.
PELOSI PICKED HIM ANYWAY.
PELOSI PICKED ERIC SWALWELL TO
INVESTIGATE TRUMP EVEN THOUGH HE
WAS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
AGAINST TRUMP, SHE PICKED
SWALWELL FOR THE INTELLIGENT
COMMITTEE, DESPITE HIS CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP TO A CHINESE SPY.
SHE PICKED DEMOCRATS ON HER
JANUARY 6 SELECT COMMITTEE EVENT
THOUGH THEY SYSTEM THEMES
CHALLENGED THE 2016 ELECTION
RESULTS, SHE PICKED A DEMOCRAT
TO INVESTIGATE THE JANUARY 6
ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL EVEN
THOUGH THAT DEMOCRAT SUED TRUMP
IN COURT.
NEARLY 500 PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
CHARGED WITH VARIOUS CRIMES
RELATED TO JANUARY 6, THOSE
CASES ARE BEING INVESTIGATE BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT WE
PROSECUTE AND SENTENCE IF
CONVICTED.
THERE IS NOT A SINGLE COP,
PROSECUTOR OR JUDGE WHO WOULD BE
ALLOWED ON THOSE CASES IF HE OR
SHE DID WHAT SCHIFF, SWALWELL OR
CASTRO DID.
NOT ONE, SHE PICKED HER OWN
BIASED MEMBERS BUT REJECTED JIM
JORDAN.
JORDAN IS THE TOP REPUBLICAN ON
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, HE WAS
ON THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE,
WHICH HAS MORE ACCESS TO MORE
SENSITIVE INFORMATION THAN ANY
COMMITTEE IN CONGRESS, JORDAN
HAS PARTICIPATED IN PREVIOUS
INVESTIGATIONS, HE WORKED HARD,
HE DIDN'T LEAK.
WHICH IS MORE THAN I COULD SAY
FOR MANY OF HIS COLLEAGUES.
BUT WHETHER YOU LIKE JIM JORDAN
OR NOT IS IRRELEVANT, WHETHER
YOU THINK THAT PREVIOUS OR
CURRENT INVESTIGATIONS ARE
APPROPRIATE IS BESEE THE POINT,
CONGRESS HAS POWER AND OFTEN
RESPONSIBILITY TO INVESTIGATE,
IT SHOULD BE FAIR.
IT IS FAIR TO ASK, WHY DEMOCRAT
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ARE FREE TO
PREJUDGE EVIDENCE, MISSPACE MISS
EVERY, RUN AGAINST THE PERSON
THEY ARE INVESTIGATING.
LEAK LIKE SIVES, YET THEY ARE
QUALIFIED FOR SERVICE ON AN
INVESTIGATIVE COMMITTEE, BUT JIM
JORDAN IS NOT?
THAT IS THE QUESTION, WHY SCHIFF
AND NOT JORDAN?
WHY SWALWELL AND NOT JORDAN?
WHY IS IT YOUR MEMBERS CAN HAVE
THEIR MINDS ALREADY MADE UP, BUT
SOMEHOW THAT IS DISQUALIFYING
FOR THE OTHER SIDE.
THE SORT OF QUESTION A SERIOUS
OBJECTIVE MEDIA WOULD ASK.
THE SORT OF QUESTION, A MEDIA
SERIOUS ABOUT SPEAKING TRUTH TO
POWER WOULD ASK.
IT IS SORT OF QUESTION A MEDIA
DEVOTED TO THE TRUTH WOULD ASK.
BUT THE MODERN MEDIA IN THIS
COUNTRY IS JUST AS PARTISAN AS
POLITICIANS THEMSELVES, TRUTH TO
POWER THEY CLAIM.
DEMOCRACY DIES IN DARKNESS, THEY
CLAIM.
WELL, IT DOESN'T DO WELL IN THE
SLOUGH OF HYPOCRISY EITHER, THAT
IS WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW, NO
SMALL PART BECAUSE THE REFEREE
IS JUST AS PARTISAN, AS T